E
BOLSTERING CLEAR SELF-DEFENSE.
ALL STRAIGHT AHEAD.
BUT FIRST THE WALLS ARE CLOSING
IN ON THE IMPLODING JOE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY BECAUSE PRICES RISE
AS COSTS SEARCH AS YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CONTINUED TO
SUFFER UNDER THE FAILING FAR
LEFT EXTREME BIDEN-HARRIS
AGENDA.
THE APPROVAL NUMBERS CONTINUE TO
HIT ONE LOW AFTER ANOTHER AND
GET THIS, ACCORDING TO A
BRAND-NEW "NEW YORK TIMES" POLL
THEM AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
BIDEN'S APPROVAL AND A DISMAL
33%.
BIDEN UNDERWATER WITH NEARLY
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC INCLUDING
YOUNG VOTERS AND INDEPENDENCE.
THE PAPER RECORD ITSELF,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEY
APPEAR TO BE TURNING ON BIDEN
RUNNING YET ANOTHER ANTI-BIDEN
PIECE THIS WEEKEND.
THE ARTICLE TITLED "AT 79,
BIDEN'S TESTING THE BOUNDARY OF
AGE AND THE PRESIDENCY" GOING
INTO GREAT DETAIL ABOUT HOW THE
WHITE HOUSE STAFF IS IN A
FULL-FLEDGED PANIC ABOUT BIDEN
STRUGGLES.
THE PIECE READS "HE OFTEN
SHUFFLES WHEN HE WALKS AND THE
AIDES ARE WORRIED HE WILL TRIP
ON A WIRE."
HE STUMBLES OVER WORDS AND THEY
HOLD THEIR BREATH TO SEE IF THEY
MAKE IT TO AN END WITHOUT A
GAFFE."
IT COMES AS DEMOCRATS AND
PRESIDENT CONTINUE TO PLAY ONE
BLAME GAME AFTER ANOTHER.
THEY BLAME IT ON THE PANDEMIC,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, VLADIMIR PUTIN,
AND THEN RICH PEOPLE.
BIG OIL, GAS STATION OWNERS,
FOX NEWS, DONALD TRUMP, EVERY
REPUBLICAN.
BIDEN TWEETING REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING NOTHING BUT OBSTRUCTING
OUR INCREDIBLE AND HEROIC
EFFORTS TO CRACK DOWN ON GAS
PRICE GOUGING.
LOWER FOOD PRICES, HEALTH CARE
COSTS AND LOWER YOUR
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AREN'T
BUYING ANY OF THIS INCLUDING
DEMOCRATS AND THEN THE POLL
FINDS A WHOPPING 64% OF
DEMOCRATS SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
AND THEY WANT SOMEONE ELSE
BESIDES JOE BIDEN RUNNING IN
2024.
OF COURSE THAT MEANS SOME
DEMOCRATS ARE FINALLY WAKING UP
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SHOWING YOU
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
WE USED TO JOKE ABOUT IT BUT
IT'S NOT FUNNY ANYMORE.
YOUR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS WEAK
AND FRAIL AND HE'S A COGNITIVE
WRECK.
HE CONTINUES TO SUFFER ONE
BIZARRE BLUNDER AFTER ANOTHER.
HERE BIDEN MAKING YET ANOTHER
TELEPROMPTER FLUB ACTUALLY
READING THE Q INSTRUCTIONS
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO READ
THEM.
SAY IT AGAIN, REPEATED, YOU'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO READ THAT.
IT HE DID IT OUT LOUD AND THEN
THEY LIED ABOUT IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S NOTEWORTHY THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF WOMAN WHO
REGISTERED TO VOTE AND CAST A
BALLOT IS CONSISTENTLY HIGHER
THAN THE PERCENTAGE OF THE MEN
WHO DO SO.
REPEAT THE LINE.
WOMEN ARE NOT WITHOUT ELECT
ORPOLITICAL POWER.
>> Sean: REPEAT.
IT JOE, YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
READ THE CUES.
MAYBE THE STAFF NEEDS TO MAKE
THE CARDS AGAIN WALK INTO THE
ROOM, SAY HELLO, SIT DOWN THEM A
LISTEN ATTENTIVELY, SAY GOODBYE,
WALK IT OFF.
BAFFLING GAFFES APPEARED TO RUN
IN THE BIDEN FAMILY.
EARLIER TODAY, THOUGH FIRST LADY
JOE BIDEN SAID THIS DURING A
LATINX CONFERENCE IN
SAN ANTONIO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS ORGANIZATION WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE DIVERSITY
OF THIS COMMUNITY AS DISTINCT AS
THE BRONX, AS BEAUTIFUL AS THE
BLOSSOMS OF MIAMI, AND AS UNIQUE
AS THE BREAKFAST TACOS HERE IN
SAN ANTONIO.
>> Sean: UNIQUE IS THE
BREAKFAST TACO.
IMAGINE IF A REPUBLICAN SAID
THAT.
IT PROBABLY BE BREATHLESS
HYSTERIA FROM THE MEDIA MOB FROM
DAYS ON END IF NOT WEEKS.
ASK YOURSELF WHAT THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE AND THIS MUCH
DISARRAY MORE THAN EVER AS WITH
THE DEMOCRATS MORE DIVIDED THAN
EVER, WHERE DO DEMOCRATS GO FROM
HERE?
WHAT'S THEIR PLAN B FOR 2024?
IS A KAMALA HARRIS,
ELIZABETH WARREN, GAVIN NEWSOM?
THE MORE WE SEE VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS, SHE MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT
SHE WAS THE HEIR APPARENT, BUT
IT'S MORE OBVIOUS EVERY DAY THAT
THEY NEVER THE NEVER-ENDING WORD
SALADS DON'T MAKE SENSE.
MIGHT TAKE HER OUT OF CONTENTION
FOR 2024 AND BEYOND ALTOGETHER.
LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN DECIPHER
AND UNDERSTAND HER ANSWER TO A
RECENT QUESTION ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURT'S ABORTION ROLE.
SEE IF YOU CAN MAKE SENSE OF
THIS.
>> I DO BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE
RIGHTLY BELIEVED BUT WE
CERTAINLY BELIEVED CERTAIN
ISSUES ARE JUST SETTLED.
THAT'S RIGHT, AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE LIVING SADLY IN A
REAL UNSETTLED TIME.
>> Sean: WENT OKAY, I GOT IT.
HARRIS' FAILURES DON'T STOP
THERE.
LET ME PLAY A SMALL SAMPLE OF
THE VICE PRESIDENTS LOW LIGHTS
AND THE PROPENSITY SHE HAS TO
REPEAT WORDS IN ONE SENTENCE
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE PASSIVE
TIME.
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE PASSING
OF TIME.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, THERE
IS GREAT SIGNIFICANCE WITH THE
PASSAGE OF TIME.
OR PARENTS ARE SEEING THE VALUE
OF EDUCATORS.
OF SAYING WE ARE NOT PAYING THEM
NEARLY ENOUGH.
>> IT'S TIME FOR US TO DO WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING AND THAT TIME
IS EVERY DAY.
EVERY DAY, IT IS TIME FOR US TO
AGREE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OUR CHILDREN,
I KNOW FOR THIS GROUP, WE
BELIEVE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
CHILDREN OF THE COMMUNITY, THEY
ARE THE CHILDREN OF THE
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS STUFF
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE YOU'RE FORCED
TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: SERIOUSLY, THE
PASSAGE OF TIME.
INAPPROPRIATE GIGGLING BY OUR
VICE PRESIDENT.
BEYOND ALL THE BLUNDERS, THE
WORD SALADS, THE FAR LEFT
CLIMATE ALARMIST CALLED CALLED
FOR THE POLICIES THERE AND
WHAT'S AT THE CORE OF BIDEN'S
FAILURES?
WE HAVE FAILED ENERGY POLICIES,
BORDER POLICIES, DAY 31 OF
JOE BIDEN ABANDONING OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE WARNING SIGNS OF THE BIDEN
ECONOMY COULD NOT BE ANY LOUDER
AS THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO
PUT IT IN AMERICA LAST POLICIES
AND PUT U.S. ENERGY SECURITY
COMPLETELY AT RISK.
DON'T FORGET IT ALL STARTED THE
SECOND JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFENSE.
HE CANCELED THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE BUT SIMULTANEOUSLY GAVE
A WAIVER FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN TO
BUILD THE NORTH STREAM TO
PIPELINE GIVING BIDEN MORE
LEVERAGE OVER OUR ALLIES IN
WESTERN EUROPE.
IT WAS JOE BIDEN WHO PUT MORE
RESTRICTIONS ON DRILLING,
JOE BIDEN WHO CONTINUES TO
ATTACK U.S. OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY, JOE BIDEN WHO STILL
HAS NO SOLUTION TO MAKE AMERICAN
ENERGY AND US ENERGY INDEPENDENT
LIKE DONALD TRUMP HE INHERITED A
COUNTRY THAT WAS ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
GET THIS, A NEW REPORT FROM
BLOOMBERG SAYS NATURAL GAS
PRICES HAVE NOW SOARED OVER 700%
ACROSS EUROPE SINCE THE START OF
THIS YEAR ALONE.
THREATENING A WORLDWIDE
RECESSION AND EVEN MORE SURGING
INFLATION.
BUT DOES YOUR PRESIDENT HAVE ANY
ANSWERS?
AVOID GOING DOWN THE SAME FAILED
PATH AS EUROPE OR WILL THE FAR
LEFT CLIMATE CULTIST CONTINUED
TO SET THE AGENDA AND CONTINUE
TO MAKE AMERICANS AND ALL OF US
IN OUR ECONOMY NEEDLESSLY SUFFER
SO DEMOCRATS CAN TRIED TO TURN
THEIR FAR LEFT CLIMATE POLICIES
AND TO WHAT THEY IS REALITY.
BIDEN IS IN AS MUCH CONTROL AS
EVER AS THE HEAD THE TRIP TO
SAUDI ARABIA, WE KNOW WHAT HE'S
GOING THERE.
HE'S BASICALLY GOING THERE TO
GET ON HIS KNEES TO KISS THE
RING OF THE CROWN PRINCE THAT HE
CALLED A MURDERER, THAT HE SAID
MURDERED THE JOURNALIST.
THE NATION HE CALLED THE PARIAH
NATION DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
YOU KNOW, JOE WILL BEG FOR MORE
OIL PRODUCTION.
MEANWHILE, WE'VE GOT HUNDREDS OF
YEARS OF HER OWN SUPPLY OF OIL
AND GAS AND COAL RIGHT HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WHY DON'T WE GO BACK TO BEING
INDEPENDENT PAYING $2 A GALLON
FOR GASOLINE INSTEAD OF $5.
WHAT DOES JOE THINK HE'S GOING
TO ACCOMPLISH HERE?
ESPECIALLY AS LEADERS AROUND THE
WORLD, OUR ALLIE